and we are live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
Sidetrack here Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel we are here with young Matthew I
miss you and I miss you
and even [__] younger Harris
how are we gentlemen
doing well a little tired been playing a
little too much Hogwarts but alive
somehow
well today we are going to be picking
our top five Sci-Fi movies of all time
that will be controversy that will be
arguing there will be Harris coming up
with some stupid [__] but
we will decide our top five so we'll get
into it straight after this
[Music]
I'm not gonna [__] around with it I am
going to throw you my first movie off
the list and I actually mean stormy is
not with us again today on phones he is
off building spaceships but he has sent
us his list and it is interesting so I
will throw them in between you guys
throwing yours so here we go first on my
list
is the Matrix
the original Matrix not the resurrection
not that one because oh my God
it's pretty bad
um I even didn't mind I like I like the
new one I don't know but the Matrix The
Matrix for me it's got to be thrown in
there because
it was groundbreaking it was sort of at
that cusp where digital
um CGI was really starting to become
um it was getting to the point where you
can't tell the difference between
reality in CGI anymore and that was that
it was they they broke a lot of rules
when they made the original Matrix and
even the the two that followed but the
original Matrix was the best one you
always know when there's a great movie
when everybody copies it for years
and that was The Matrix all over people
copied that down film over and over and
over again so
um that's why for me the Matrix is one
of the greatest Sci-Fi movies ever made
and it is
full on it's just it's a proper sci-fi
movie as well because it breaks you know
it makes you think it's got you know I'm
not even sure it makes sense in places
which is always a good sign of a good
sci-fi movie if you're like that makes
sense and like yeah
um it's you know it it but it it it's
it's designed to try to expand your
thinking it's not just about what's on
the screen you're supposed to try to
read between the lines a little bit
you're supposed to try to you know
it like what makes you think so now
that's why for me the Matrix is in the
top five do you guys have any arguments
with the Matrix because you know
is it it's actually in my list but it's
not it's in my list as well we're gonna
have some layover on that one
excellent I'd love to live a little bit
of crossover I actually guarantee you
that at least one film on my list you
both of you will go no but we'll see
what happens so that's first on my list
is the Matrix guys
um in the comments today guys if you
want to get in there tell us your five
movies I've already had some comments on
the short edit earlier I will share
those in a little bit
um so you guys are gonna have your voice
as well but we are going to pick our top
five today that's when they are going to
really start
Matthew sir what is your first point I I
should say by the way before we get into
it we're not going to probably put these
in order
it's not that that's not my fifth
favorite movie of all time because
actually getting these into an order
was actually quite hard picking a
favorite for me was actually quite easy
but
beyond that so that's all we're not
doing it in all in reverse order again
if you want you can if you want or you
can just throw them out there but what
have you what is what is fifth on your
list sir
my fifth is Planet of the Apes
no
I'm
a planet of the [__] eggs for you
oh you kicked yourself
which one the um
the originals The Originals yeah okay
not the Mark Wahlberg one not the new
ones the new ones are all right but I
really really enjoyed the The Originals
growing up I think he was I've got all
of them I think it was Marky Mark wasn't
it I think he was
um okay Charlie I really enjoyed them
I think
it was one of them films I could watch
with my dad
growing up and
I don't know I just have really good
memories though it's just one of them
films it is as a child watching it
I've just got good memories
that's how I that's how I made this list
it's it's do I have good memories and
did they have some sort of was it like a
moment in my life that I can think back
and be like yes
that like made my love of this genre
essentially and that's one of them it's
not it's not it's number five
so it's not wild
because that is and that's what movies
and things are supposed to do aren't
they particularly movies over a TV
series where a TV series you've got
hours and hours and hours of TV to
impact movies uh sharp sharp hits you
know and
if it has an impact on your life but
that that when I say to you what's your
favorite it jumps straight out of you
that's the point Nostalgia you know
um it doesn't I think like accuracy has
said Nostalgia doesn't necessarily make
a good movie
but it's what's important to you
and that's
that's the thing isn't when we're
talking about what is good
it's what's important to you these these
lists are all very objective but these
are personal to us these are our lists
so your list is gonna be different to
mine
um and even people in the audience
they're going to be like well I don't
like that film that's that's fair you
can have your own guarantee it's not
making the top five when we do the video
at the end
but if I say about five it'll always
stay there
the final sequence is Iconic at the end
of the day you know that you you crazy
it is Iconic so you can't really argue
with that I've seen I've seen every
single one I've got them all on DVD I
absolutely love them I've seen every
single one all right
what is fifth on your list sir well this
is the one I won't throw a wrench in at
number one just uh just to keep you a
little uh leviated there but uh
this is a little bit different it's it's
1973 it's a French film so I have to
read a bunch of subtitles whenever I I
watch it but the 1973 animated Fantastic
Planet film I think did a lot for sci-fi
I love it it's just a fun film just to
watch in general it's a little dated I
guess in
animation but at the same time we go
back and watch Steamboat Willie kind of
Mickey Mouse stuff so it's really not
all that dated so I the reason I put it
up there is because
it was it wasn't the first I guess
sci-fi movie off world off the planet
Earth but it was probably the largest
scoped it was probably at the time
animated movie yeah it very well might
be the first sci-fi animated film uh
because I can't think of many other
animated films besides I I'm sure there
are but that's the first like mainstream
animated film that wasn't like a Disney
princess or or Mickey Mouse or something
other sort that I can think of uh I'm
sure there are others of course but
animation it had a big kind of a dip in
the water there scope wise and concept
wise for sci-fi I think it really took
it to kind of the next level and allowed
people that brain space to say okay well
let's let's take these things off world
let's actually do some weird stuff let's
get trippy and interesting with it
yeah so that's fantastic that's another
thing is that pushing boundaries that
film definitely pushed boundaries
um I have watched it because it was part
of my um education when I was a kid that
um I'd have mate who's definitely a
Sci-Fi geek and he's not he's one he's
that guy throwing comic books at you you
gotta read this you gotta read that you
gotta read this
um and he said no you've got to sit down
and watch Fantastic Planet and um and
and watch it and I have to admit I sat
there all the way through going
it's French and but no no just watch the
Aesthetics and everything else but it is
it should be if you if you've got kids
and you want them to understand sci-fi
it's a good foundation it's a good
education very
um
my list for number four is actually
matches
um stormy's number five so I'll throw
them in at the same time so number five
on our stormys list who you faxed it in
before the show started
is aliens
and that's also number four on my list
the first alien if you'd have come up
with that I'd have said no come on I
said full on sci-fi is that a horror
movie
yeah you know it's it's one of those
things that you could toss a coin but
aliens is a sci-fi movie yeah it may be
an action movie as well but you know
that's that's you know you're really
splitting hairs then but
um
it had some iconic sequences
get away from me you [__]
um the tank I still want one
with the gun that comes down at the back
and everything
um
you know the the knife
there are so many great scenes in that
film that you know sometimes every so
often that when the director's cut comes
out to these films
and you've got to go well does it add
anything to the movie or is it just
you know padding and you watch that film
and you go editors need to get get out
of their own [__] way because after
that alien should be a three-hour movie
there is so much story that they just
didn't tell because they cut it out
because they wanted it to be less than
two hours
at the Cinematic release that needed
to be there that just weren't
um the director's cut is is is the
version you want to watch that you know
you see the whole thing with the um the
families at the on the base and you know
the on the refinery the parrot so the
terraforming station beforehand the
north all the stuff you don't see all
the stuff with the little kid whose name
has just come out my head I want to say
Spud that's not right
what's a little kid's name
anyway
um you know you essentially see her
beforehand with a family and everything
and you know it's not
the a lot of the impact of where why
she's in the film later is lost because
of the editing that the um the you know
the the executives basically forced on
the director to get it as a cinematic
release of less than two hours and Newt
thank you your old Yorkshire geek you
absolutely beautiful people being
um Newt whatever Spud from
it was a couple of seconds later with
Newt as well well done so
um so but yeah um undiscovered I'm sorry
aliens is not just a great movie it's a
great action movie it's a great thing
it's one of those very rare films that
is virtually perfect the casting's
perfect the story is compelling it goes
on you know it's like you you it's one
of those very rare films that you can
watch more than once and you'll notice
something different each time
um it generally will make your heart
pulse
it's just a perfect movie
um and yeah number four on my list and
number five on our stormy
so yeah
number four on your list Matthew sir
my fourth is again a very nostalgic pick
it's E.T
oh
I I really like EDU so the reason so
growing up I didn't watch many films
growing up
okay
but the films I watched I know what
films I liked I watched over and over
and over again yeah
ET was one of those those films for me
it was
I think it probably is the reason why I
started getting into like liking like
aliens and science fiction and
spaceships and and are we alone in the
universe kind of thing because I wanted
to be early on the bike flying over the
moon like through the Moon
I wanted that
I want to be a little E.T in my back
Garden I want to look after him I want
him to go Matt instead of Elliot but
yeah it's it's it's
one of them it's probably more like a
family a family sci-fi it's not like a
full-on
like epic sci-fi it's a family film
but it's it's one that I love so
it's great it helps it helps kids
conceptualize sci-fi kind of like we
just talked with a fantastic planet and
same thing with rise of the planet or
Planet of the Apes in general not Rise
of Planet of the Apes but those are like
great family films as well as just
conceptual things for kids to wrap their
brains around and it's so much fun to do
that
yeah now I I agree I I hate eating I
think it's boring
um I think Steven Spielberg
needs a kick no it's not not that far
it's it's a good film it's got fun bits
in it but I I personally I've always I
feel in fact even when I was a kid I
found it boring
oh look the CT let's not TT isn't it
lovely
but when's ET gonna eat someone
three films I can think of
that would be in the same same vein as
ET for me so you've got ET Bicentennial
Man and AI
all right you know that that kid I
watched them constantly I love them I
absolutely love them I don't know I
don't know what it is about them but I
think they're all pretty similar in
terms of
being boring in my head no they're not
boring they're really good films
Bicentennial Man
oh [__] I absolutely love it you and
me we're the same
I love it it's such a good film
yeah but you know hey currencies just
said what makes E.T sci-fi uh aliens
he builds a radio to phone home at
science fiction now it is um it is
science fiction I don't know what else
you would call it what is it a rom-com
it's not is it so um no it's an eating
it's it's a Sci-Fi so okay
um or generalization just put in fifth
elements and I never even thought about
that God damn it Fifth Element right
okay
um I will tell you the fourth one on
stormy's list before and my throat over
to Harris so um his fourth thing was
Moon
um a movie that really reminded me of
Silent Running Back in the day is like
there was like a 70s or very early 80s
movie it's a guy on this big spaceship
with plants and things and he's just got
this one little box robots from but moon
is a very similar movie for me it's like
Sam Rockwell stars in it and Sam
Rockwell's a really great character
actor you know he's just like
um
when he get when he fully gets into a
part and he can be silly and things it
Moon's great
um and it's it's one of those movies
that really does draw you in it's one of
those films actually I would say that
all the way through you're thinking I
should probably turn this off I'm not I
don't really get it I'll just watch the
next two minutes and the next thing you
know you've watched the whole damn film
and thoroughly enjoyed it
um and it you know it's not it doesn't
quite
I don't know you could even argue that
nothing really happens in it
yeah
yeah it's kind of just saying Rockwell
being Sam Rockwell in space and
but it's such a brilliant
character-driven movie
um again it's only really sci-fi because
it exists in space but it's the cycle
there's so much psychology involved in
the things
um and yeah I I yeah no I just I I love
it it's a great movie
so how about you Harris what's on your
next so I'm I'm not tossing another
Fantastic Planet in here but this one
very well might show up on some other
list down the road but Blade Runner the
original one I I had to kind of decide
between Blade Runner 2049 and Blade
Runner but Blade Runner just kind of
it's it's at the ground for almost it
didn't set the grounds for elevated
sci-fi per se because Kubrick kind of
started that off with 2001 and uh A
Clockwork Orange but Blade Runner showed
that you didn't have to be Stanley
Kubrick to make elevated sci-fi per se
so that was nice
and it's just great it's a solid film
always will be pretty solid and
Harrison Ford running around thank you
please more Harrison Ford sci-fi
it's it's again another one of those
films so isn't it that it's like it's
one of those read between the lines
films it's it's there's so many layers
to that movie
um if it was released now it's probably
called woke but I mean there's so many
different things about Freedom it's
about
um our gender bite there's all sorts of
things in there that uh that if you read
between the lines it's supposed to it's
it's not just a film rudger hour and
punching and it's it's supposed to leave
you with something you know
you're supposed to take something away
from that movie and um yeah that's one
of the reasons why I I would yeah I
would say that's that's a grateful it's
a great thing and it so easily could
have just been Punchy punchy
just so straightforward and they decided
to just take the perfect route with it
thank you thank you no 100 I agree with
you I've got to write it down haven't I
uh what's it called again Blade Runner
not 2049 because I know you'd kick me
off immediately if I told you that one
that wasn't great I'll give you that it
wasn't great I like it
yeah
number three on my list
oh this might be controversial
um it's RoboCop
now
boys like RoboCop because it's it
there's violence
there's um a cool robot if you're a
villain and you can run though you're
escaping this thing I mean
hi I'm being fairy will shoot you but
um
you're talking about a film that is that
actually has loads of layers to it as
well I mean that should be fair
always sort of like takes all those
layers and like all the subtle layers
that are supposed to be in the movie
when you first read between the lines
and he goes there I mean that's it then
he shoves them right down your throat
um but I kind of like that you know he's
like he wanted to make a subtle thing
about environmentalism and he did the
whole bit about um Sun cream three
thousand
and so he doesn't make it even remotely
subtle
um but I quite like that as well but the
thing for me is that RoboCop was so
unique when it came out nobody's ever
quite seen anything like it I remember
seeing it when I was a kid my mom and
dad didn't realize what it was and so
they let me watch it and then they're
going his Blue's arm off
um I even love RoboCop too but the first
one
it was so extremely
out there in every way it was it was a
proper balls out moving I love watching
documentaries about how it was made I
love things about how like it nearly
killed the actor and Paul Weller and it
pulling up Paul Weller that's a singer
in it
that sounds right
just a second just a second just a
second I think but anyway I love things
like how when he was wearing the suit it
was so it was really really heavy and it
nearly killed him Peter Weller thank you
poor well is a singer
um
so
um so what they by the end of the movie
they had to put like an air conditioning
unit in it so there's an air
conditioning unit just off off screen
with a pipe basically going into his
back of his foot injecting cool air up
one leg
to stop him from dying
um and it was seriously that bad the way
this the suit weighed so much money he
was losing like a kilogram every time he
put the damn thing on he weighed less by
the time he took off
um I'd love things like that
um but you just know that other leg the
one leg that because you know the body
got all the air it needed but that other
leg that didn't have the AC
swamp leg every day
um I love things like as well like like
and you know the the scene at the start
of the movie when they um blew all his
arms off and Paul Weller got blown apart
and going forward
um they actually and they had
um people on Seth throwing up
because it was so it was all very much
um physical special effects and they've
done it so well they had to do it
towards the end of the movie because
they were worried about like freaking
people out and things but apparently
crew was sick
um and it it shows on screen
um I loved watching it when I was a kid
and like ITV and like late at night and
um and they cut all those bits out and
he's like oh no I've been sharp boom and
then you're like well then you fall over
and then it would cut and he's dead he
was like well I know what happened why
did his arm fall off and it's just like
I love those cut movies like that it was
just awesome but yeah RoboCop for me it
was it was groundbreaking properly
groundbreaking and that's what I want in
the Sci-Fi movies much so I want to be
entertained I want stuff to blow up
because I'm a complete child and I I
wanted to maybe make me think about it
and RoboCop made me think about it and I
want a film that I watch over and over
and over again and all of the films on
my lists I've watched probably 10 12
more times in my life and will always
watch if I get an opportunity and if I
see it late at night on TV I'm gonna
watch it and this would 100 be one of
those films
um
Matt number three on your list sir
my third is Matrix so your fifth but why
for you
I don't know I really
again it's Nostalgia I don't know it's
one of them I've been I've always
watched it
I always go back to it because it's I
think just
a good movie forget the Sci-Fi element
of it it's just it's just a good
like the concept is good are we in a
simulation how can we get out blah blah
I've always liked that
side of
life kind of thing like are we in a
simulation I've always been interested
in that kind of stuff
I don't believe it I don't think we are
I hope we are
because I want to go and fight robots
I really really want Morpheus to come
into my office
enhance me a red and a blue pill
but yeah I'm saying no but yeah I do
want that no I don't know it's one of
them I I've enjoyed every single Matrix
film I even enjoyed the recent Matrix
film I know a lot of people didn't like
it and I don't understand why people
didn't like it I just thought it was
good
but it was it was matrix it's it's it's
how if if a new Stargate came out
I would still watch it
even if it was crap if everyone else
said it was crap I'd still watch it and
I probably still find enjoyment because
it's Stargate and that's all it is with
Matrix for me it's matrix it's
continuing the story I want to know what
happens
I just love Matrix I love it
okay
um
I remember watching The Matrix that's
that's the thing where this is if I
remember the first time I watched a
movie then it's added impact on me and I
remember watching The Matrix but the
main thing I remember about it was I was
walking out the cinema with my
girlfriend at the time and she just
literally went
what the [__] was that and I'm trying to
explain it to her
why did he wake up with no hair because
that's the real him
well then what
why did you think
yeah I've tried explaining the Matrix to
like my partner and stuff before and
it's yeah
um if you don't enjoy it and you're not
invested when you're watching it you're
not going to understand it and that's
fair enough but I'm not gonna realize
yeah you know yeah
the secret is though there isn't a spoon
so as long as you remember that
there is
bendable the amount of times I've sat
there with a spoon I just think there's
no spoon there
like
um you're together
it's a rubber spoon
okay bend it back again look
oh man
um number three on stormy's list he went
a bit higher Brown we're here we'll go
with mobile cooker book up stormy's 2001
A Space Odyssey on his list now that is
a proper sci-fi movie it regularly makes
the top five top ten Sci-Fi movies of
all time when voted by critics and
Rotten Tomatoes number three
um it's again hey look there's loads
going on in that movie
um it's iconic you know this whole thing
with how and everything is you know
everybody knows that even if you've
never watched the film you know that
little what's up huh what's going on you
know everybody knows that
um everybody knows
no that's that's something else anyway
but everybody knows the monolisk and the
thing
um
it's it's obviously film I haven't
watched in a very long time but it is
Iconic and um hey they're on about
making a remake and a streaming service
for Amazon and now they now Amazon own
it
um not a film an actual streaming series
I don't think there's enough story there
for me to actually spread out but hey
there's three or four books they made it
into three or four novels so there is an
official sequel technically that came
out in the 80s I believe uh Kubrick
didn't direct it but I think he produced
it uh I'm not positive on that but there
is a technical sequel I think there are
two books that followed I think it was
22 2001 as well anyway and but anyway
there's yeah there's a few books there
is a bit of material there so yeah 2001
A Space Odyssey a bit high brow
book
that's his that's the storm is third
list because he's old and he's not here
to defend himself so Harris third on
your list sir
oh I I had to make it just so different
on this one just really throw something
out there that nobody would expect
Matrix
reloaded no I'm kidding just Matrix uh
well no I mean the same reason that you
had it on number five same reason Matt
has it for number three all those
reasons it's just such a perfect
conceptual film which is what sci-fi
films tend to be yeah and it helps you
wrap your brain around something that
you don't necessarily think about all
the time but very well could be going on
a daily basis and how would we ever know
any better
unless you get a little red blue pill
whatever
uh it's just I mean since we kind of
talked all the Sci-Fi aspects of it up
it's just such a great film for Action
as well for how it implemented all these
cool sci-fi elements into their action
and into
modern and and and just not not
necessarily modern Kung Fu or anything
like that in modern karate all these
different things they they put modern
fighting styles and old fighting styles
into the film Incorporated them well and
made them make sense in a world that
didn't make sense to us and it did it
excellently superbly yeah I mean that's
the first time I feel like we actually
saw and you know I kind of talked about
it a couple weeks ago I I'm not much of
an anime person but I I started with
Attack on Titan I like that
but the cool thing about anime has
always been you can do these really
awesome fight sequences that you can't
do in live action and Matrix prove that
you could you just have to be willing to
go that stylized you have to be willing
to do that kind of
otherworldly kind of thing and they did
and it's just it's it stands the test of
time because of it you have to I feel
like you're willing to spend six months
training as well I feel like the fight
scenes in Matrix are so good they could
be in any film and make that film better
it doesn't have to be about that story
but you pull it in in that style of
fighting and it would just Elevate the
film it's just fantastic but I love the
fight scenes
in the first film the fight scene in the
first film with
um Neo and Smith in the subway
even if one thing that didn't quite work
in the second one I'm gonna forget which
was whether it was Resurrection or and
that's that Resurrection uh whether it
was reboot the the one with like the
million Smiths the million Smith's fight
scene which didn't quite the third one I
think isn't it
that is it reloaded then then what no I
think that was it was the second one
because it was the first time we see I
think it was reloaded and then
revolutions was the third one I think
okay but anyway reloaded so the other
fight sequence with the hundreds and
hundreds of Smiths the first time we
have that fight not the second time so
um that didn't quite work the CGA wasn't
quite there it was still a bit
plastisiny
and where the at times the
um particularly Neo didn't you know I
think like CJ with the arms and legs
it's slightly too long and you can tell
it's like yeah
but
they were so it was really was The
Cutting Edge of the technology was what
the technology was capable of and
through the original trilogy it was all
about 100
commitment from the actors and the team
behind it and the waskowski brothers and
and Keanu Reeves
all of the special effects all the fight
sequences everything was always there
are so many things in those first three
films that we've never seen before
the fight sequence on the motorway with
the ghosts
and everything yeah we'd never seen
anything like that ever and whether you
don't like the movies or not you've got
to tip your hat
to the effort and the special effects
that went into it because nobody's ever
done it before
and it I agree with you on the uh on the
on the second movie fight scene in that
it didn't look great
but conceptually I thought that was a
fantastic fight scene oh yeah amazingly
it worked I would say mostly it worked
but at times you're like a bit it's not
quite it takes it takes you out of it
when you can see it's not real when it's
a little bit more plasticky and it
wasn't as immersive
but if they if they redid it with like
better CGI it could be amazing
the thing is you couldn't remake it now
because they've already done it if they
tried to redo it they'd be like yeah
you're just trying to do that
it wouldn't work if you choose right I'd
try to do it now but yeah
they could remaster the disk set or the
the digital disk set at some point but
it wouldn't be worth the money that
would cost so expensive that would be
expensive
[Music]
um
right we are three we have our top
couple left to go so I am going to run a
couple of adverts we are going to
breathe and then we are going to be
straight back
nine chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about our new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to new
stories that we break check out some of
the news articles that we have already
at nineshavrons.com Star Trek also has
some amazing merch get yours today and
show your support at sidestrek.com
if I could see him out there going
[Laughter]
thank you
when you've recorded it and you've heard
it a million times it gets really old
yeah you have to you have to do that
again at some point we need our
adversary but right so before we get
into I've got I've been I have been
checking out the lists as we've done
three and write down any of that that
are thrown up a couple of movies we
haven't mentioned yet Tron Close
Encounters I don't know I don't know if
it's on your list guys but cousin came
to the fifth guys
it's not analysis War of the Worlds
original or actually I didn't even hate
the Tom Cruise version Galaxy Quest has
been thrown up a few times that's a
comedy so not allowed
um Forbidden Planet as well has been
thrown up it's another movie that might
you know get a remake at some point in
the near future so I will
um we'll do our top two and then I will
just read a couple of um comments we had
on the short video I did earlier as well
Paul Maloney actually just throw up with
the abyss which actually really really
nearly made my top five it it was if if
I had another one it would be on my list
yeah it was it was really close for me
that is again talking about special
effects and stuff we've never seen
before
oh they had to create the technology to
do that whole water sequence it didn't
exist
um and I love that whole submerged
um rig thing that they are just I love
that film that was that that again that
it's a bit slow and it's a bit goes on a
bit in places
um to be perfect but it's [__] close
it's really good though I'll never
forget the first time I watched Ed
Harris and the rest of that cast just
kind of
liquid oxygen and then to start having
to breathe liquid oxygen that was just
oh it was intense
storming actually worked on that movie
as well and he says um it was telling a
story about how somebody nearly drowned
because that wasn't I always thought
that was you know these those you know
those cups sometimes they've got two
layers and it looks good liquid it looks
like there's liquid in there but it's
not really so I always thought that that
the mask had two things so when the
water's coming up it just looks like
it's filling up but it's not really and
this act is perfect no they filled the
water up and someone nearly died
[Music]
great movie
so love story for that one so number two
on my list this is my
um curveball and it's a very personal
movie
um and it's Star Trek and the
Undiscovered Country
and now if you're a regular Sidetrack
you've heard the story a million times
and I'm sorry but I'm gonna tell it
again it's it was I actually snuck out
of school
to go and watch this movie so I sat in
the cinema on my own there was me in my
school uniform and two men Sat one was
over there one was over there in the
cinema at three o'clock in the afternoon
and watching Star Trek the music of the
country I am not going to pretend for a
second that this is the greatest movie
ever made because it isn't right there
are parts of this movie that were bloody
awful
the open sequence though is amazing
where Praxis explodes and it's like
Sulu and the um Excelsior have to fly
into the wave and all this sort of thing
there's the bit where sulu's flying in
to help the battle and just you'll fly
apart fire apart then that generally
make my give me goosebumps
um you know there's the whole thing with
the Klingons quote and Shakespeare
because you've never heard
um Shakespeare listen we've hidden the
original Klingon no it's Shakespeare it
was the original is English but anyway
Carol it's just there are parts that
move out they're iconic but for me
I was four to 13 or 14 years old I'd
never seen a movie on my own at Cinema
before I'd never seen a sci-fi movie at
the cinema before I loved Star Trek Star
Trek the Next Generation had just come
out so I was already obsessed and then
this movie came out and for me it's the
best of all Star Trek films I adore it
and I cannot do a list of five
Sci-Fi movies and not have Undiscovered
Country on there for very personal
reasons and I will fight and I will
remind you who's in charge when we do
our top five
okay
that's not making the top five because
it's very personal to me but
it's it's I love it the whole speech at
the end with William Shatner does make
me want to throw up into a bucket and
and it's just [__] we're together and
you're together and we're all together
I'll just [__] off will no Billy but um
but the film is glorious and I love it I
just adore it so that is my second one
and I make no apologies for it but I am
kind of sorry
Matt number two on your list sir
Back to the Future
I had Back to the Future on my list I've
crossed out about four times I was
waiting for someone to say it
every single Bachelor I really want them
to make a fourth one but they just can't
um understand why but I really want a
fourth one
so I've seen I've seen um a concept of
what the fourth one would be and it
comes from The Telltale Game that they
they released right and it sounds
amazing right so after this live show
everyone go and type into YouTube Back
to the Future four it's basically clips
from the game but they've turned into a
movie it is so good I want them to make
it
because it would be fantastic and it's
essentially a Doc Brown because he's
been traveling back in time Great temple
duplicate so one of them turns evil and
it's really [__] good it's so good
okay all right but that being said
that you know there's not gonna be a
fourth one but the original trilogy
absolutely love it the first film is the
best one obviously the second film is is
good
I re I really like the third one
I like it better than the second one
I don't know why I think it's because
it's a western and like I kind of like
westerns yeah
they made three very different movies
but with the same
Essence to them though didn't they so it
definitely was a part that was the first
film I ever remember making a Trilogy it
was like part one part two and part
three I don't ever they must have been
filmed there were films before that
because like the Godfather the first one
I remember them doing it and and they
filmed the second or third one back to
back I never I don't ever remember them
doing you know the film's been done like
that before but it was so ridiculously
popular
um
there aren't many movies that's ever
been made that have such a wide audience
and a
a fan base to it that that is so loyal
because it's like you said it's just a
good film
an iconic yes it's iconic yeah the
people have been trying to film it's one
of them skateboards ever since
it's one of them films even in 50 years
people still watching it in 100 years
people still be watching it it's one of
this timeless
yeah it's also one of those films that
they can never reboot they can never
remake it because people would go ape
[__] and there aren't many films E.T
like you mentioned earlier they can
never re they can never remake ET people
will go ain't [__]
um Back to the Future is one of those
films as well they can't remix Star Wars
they can't remake that
um the original I mean
um they can never remake Star Wars A New
Hope
Back to the Future is one of those films
that you just can't do it and because
Michael J fox
and you know um these it's it's they are
the character and you can't you can't
recast it it's impossible
yeah and people would go apesion I mean
it's so iconic that it has churned off
just a funny parody of it turned off the
most successful probably Sci-Fi show
ever made per capita Rick and Morty I
mean for they're only what six seasons
in now and like if you had to do a most
successful Sci-Fi show per episode made
it has to be Rick and Morty there's just
no doubt about that
and it's just a spin-off Rarity is
ingrained in society as well a bit like
oh yeah future is especially now like
everyone knows pickle Rick everyone
knows
which and Matt have you seen where I
think it was just Adult Swim doing a
commercial ad but they did Christopher
Lloyd and
it wasn't Daniel Radcliffe it was
somebody as like a live-action Morty but
Christopher Lloyd came in as a
live-action Rick yeah yeah I've seen it
yeah I I would worry about a fourth
uh Back to the Future right now just
because it's so far past it but if they
gave me a live-action Rick and Morty
with with Christopher I mean
it'd be so much fun a little hot water
right now but
well he's he's sacked Now isn't he
they're getting a new actor in so
yeah yeah he's just right Justin
roilance is his name yes
at this point he was essentially just
voice voice Talent anyway from what
people have been saying and Dan Harmon's
always been the genius behind the show
anyway so the good writing's still going
to be there we just had to have a good
voice mimic
there's plenty of people that can do
Rick and Morty oh yeah
there's so many people and they're like
gee Rick I can't do it but do you agree
you sound exactly like him why don't you
[__] get hired by him
while we're mentioning Robert zemeckis
though and Back to the Future number two
on stormy's list was not one of Robert
zemex's biggest movies but if you're
going to talk about
a realistic sci-fi the thinking man's
sci-fi
contact
based on a Carl Sagan story
um you know that you know like Carl
Sagan the scientists actually had a lot
to do with
how realistic this story was Matthew in
the hanuki star Jody Foster
um 1997 I'm reading I've acted Wikipedia
because I couldn't remember Joey
Foster's name so while we were talking
I'm sorry quickly I've got a very
knowledgeable I know this movie
backwards
um
you know it was it actually was a very
commercially successful movie
um but it's realistic
um and it was supposed to make you think
about if aliens really did turn up on
this planet I mean we're talking about
science fiction which it is because it's
never happened but it's heavy science
you know
um and we're talking about Matthew
mcconicky what other film can we maybe
mention that he starred in that
I'm just saying that a cup a couple
we'll get there we'll get there okay
but but yeah you know it's
it is
it's a great movie
um it's not the short film I would watch
more than once it's it's sort of like
the Martian for me I love it because it
makes me think but I I have to be a
little bit more entertained than that
for me to to Really impact me for me to
really love it you know
um but but you know a great movie so
Harris Harris what was number three on
your list
three was Matrix Matrix I didn't write
it down what's number four on your list
sir
or four number two two on two sorry
that's the way I've written it on these
on here well two I I almost put this in
number one just because it's it's like
iconic enough where it it's almost
shoehorned in at number one everywhere
but thank you for for beating me to the
punch stormy uh because 2001 of Space
Odyssey is Stanley Kubrick's magnum opus
nonetheless he made a mini a great film
after that but
The Shining still not as magnum opus
the Clockwork Orange is not the magnum
opus
2001 A Space Odyssey is the magnum opus
and rightfully so it's just so
well done for everything we said earlier
and it's just
it it makes you think it's one of those
conceptual films that it is kind of slow
at times but I think that pacing helps
your brain kind of keep up with what's
actually going on yeah and it's just
I I I when I watched it probably way too
young to actually understand what was
going on but that made me want to go
back and watch it over and over again
until I did
um I I still probably couldn't tell you
exactly what's going on but that's
that's the best part about it is you
watch it over and over again and find
something new about it find something
new within like the script not even just
what's going on visually but what
Kubrick wrote down for the characters to
say and that's just oh it's it's just
not perfect I love it I'm visually
beautiful as well which is something
that was
um sometimes overlooked that actually
the I mean I think it did win didn't it
win an Academy Award for these special
effects oh it should have because I mean
I I can't think of a sci-fi film that
hasn't taken some kind of
inspiration from at least the visual
aspect of 2001 since that yeah every
everything that whole color theme that's
psychedelic it's it's so perfect for it
yeah the the use of music is so
important
in a movie like that and in any movie
really but
um when you say 2001 Space Odyssey and
everybody I can't play I play the music
now but then we'd get a bloody copyright
thing against us
um
what you know sometimes they'll say you
know like films can't or or a picture
can't make noise but you know you hear
it in your head straight away
um
every aspect of that movie was seriously
thought about is my point nothing was
left a chance
the visuals are perfect every single
word of the script is focused and to the
point every silence is
specific and to the point Glenn yeah I I
find it a little bit difficult hard
going it's not the sort of film you just
watch on a Friday night because you want
you know chill out sort of thing but
it's no it's a it's a great movie
um and you can't argue with it really
you can't argue with one in the top ten
it's we're going to struggle not putting
in our top five when we do the list oh
it's just so meticulous and perfect I
mean Kubrick was the guy to do algebra
and calculus just for fun in his home on
his free time the little free time he
had was all right let me uh fix the
brain up a little bit and you two can
just see it in the films he made so well
done
perfect right so number one on my list
now this is the only one I've actually
put in order the other films such double
point in order this film is not just
the greatest sci-fi movie ever made
hands down it's one of the greatest
movies ever made
it's perfect all right the special
effects are subtle
but stand up today and this is a film
that's 30 years old
it's hard it was casting was perfect
the
um writing was perfect it's got
characters in it that we still that has
been remade and redone over and over and
over again there is the pacing the
editing everything
perfect it is genuinely one of
a handful of movies that there is
nothing wrong with it
it's the predator
the original Predator with Arnold
Schwarzenegger is
perfection
I can watch that movie over and over and
over again it will never be it's like a
bit like die hard in the same respect
that they can remake it as many times as
they like
they can't outdo the original and and
shouldn't try to be honest because you
just can't
it's it's been it's a film has been
remade a million times by different you
know with different titles and different
things and copied them a million times
um
Predator is one of the greatest movies
ever made
done end of argument
it's going off of our list
Matt what's top of your list what's
wrong on the top of your list
is Terminator
wrong
um
Terminator or Terminator 2.
I'm going to say original Terminator but
I I I I prefer T2 personally probably T2
I'd say T2 T2 yeah
Terminator is great they're both
wonderful
um and
again if we're talking about special
effects and things though like
Terminator 2 again they created the
technology T2 T2 is definitely what I'm
gonna pick because I watched that before
I watched any of the before I watched
the original it's the it's the movie
that got me into Terminator
yeah and what made me fall in love with
Arnie as as the Terminator that's why I
don't like
Matthew and Arnie sitting in a tree
anyway
um my dad only watched the original
Terminator late at night in a Friday and
I I now look back on my childhood
thinking my parents were really not
thinking this crap through
um I must have been about they wanted
you out the way and he went the other
way they wanted me traumatized I think
just just give them some crazy movie
real quick yeah yes let him stay up till
11 o'clock watching 18.
if he cries too
get everything seen on T2 like freaked
me out as a kid where she's there on the
train length fence and she's like that
Skin's getting ripped oh yeah and all
that like what the [__] I mean I thought
it was awesome I'm like what the [__]
[Music]
Ed in that area in the film you're just
like oh okay
yeah yeah and then you just see the
skulls and the Terminator just crushes
one of them I'm like
that's so good one of the again we're
talking about iconic scenes that
everybody knows
um
Terminator 2 is full of them
it's absolutely full of them but the
original Terminator was as well when he
walks into the police and he's I'll be
back he's he he carried on with that for
the next 40 Years of his career he was
always coming back
um but then he blows that that whole
police station away that stayed with me
when I was a kid now when my mum and dad
let me stay up at late night watching
that and I'm just like what the now we
look back and they're thinking my 15
year old kid won't watch that well no
too bad they've watched much worse now
but anyway my 12 or 13 kid maybe
wouldn't
um that is Terminator and then
Terminator 2 is what I consider is I
remember my lad my eldest
and he's talked to me and he's like he's
not watching any of these films you know
I'm like he's about 15 I'm like mate
we've got to start your movie education
Die Hard Predator Terminator two you've
got and Terminator you've got to watch
these movies immediately first Lethal
Weapon these are the films that these
this is your education
crack on this is what you should be
comparing every modern film too because
they were they were as close to
Perfection as you can get
everything ever since has just been
trying to use CGI to you know the first
avatar maybe that you know all these
sort of films
they're perfect so yeah
but uh so Terminator 2 mate it's a it's
a freaking good shout I I all terminated
to be fair you could toss a coin depends
what you want yeah Terminator 2 is a bit
glossier it's a bit more special effect
it's a bit more thing but the Terminator
the first Terminator was definitely
grittier
I love to see Arnie as a bad guy
I think the original Terminator was a
bit in a way a little bit more scary
because it was
yeah the CGI wasn't wasn't that great
but it looked freaky
it looked I didn't take his sunglasses
off and he's got the red it was yeah
you can tell it's a bloody um thing he
had like because
um sometimes when you're watching
something and you can tell it's CGI
or you can tell it's a prosthetic you
you can kind of distance yourself from
it but when it's
I'm not going to say when it was done
[__] because it wasn't done [__] for the
time it was all right for the time
but
yeah it was all like
stop motion wasn't it for yeah so the
actual movement
yeah
those films were brilliant as well you
know time traveling back in time to kill
the mother of the day you know like
again made you think it made you like oh
okay now and again we're not seeing if
you like it before
but like I said again in T2 they had to
create the technology for lots of those
special effects with the T-1000 because
it didn't or T2000 it was T2000 I forget
um
yeah T-1000
um they had to create the technology it
didn't exist and that's again James
Cameron being a bastard to just start
going this is what I want to do we can't
do it well we'll have to figure out how
this is yeah okay
it was one of the scariest parts
like when I grow up the scariest part
was
you know when his hand turned into a
knife and he's got his hand in the
woman's eye
but they're mimicking her voice through
the marathon but yeah she's like taking
I know the husband he's still drinking
the milk and he goes
yeah but the mimicking the the voice of
like when are you coming home John when
you that was freaky yeah like looking
back it's not really that scary it's
just like a knife in someone's face
essentially but it's the it's the
mimicking someone's voice
yeah it's just free it's it's it was
freaky at the time well he did it in
Terminator as well done it in the first
Terminator after he'd killed the front
but now it's a great movie great movie
good shot definitely gonna oh it's
difficult not to put it in it's so good
number one pick
was June now I don't know if he means
the original June or Patrick Stewart or
the new version
um I think you could I mean I think
they're very similar in lots and lots of
ways so um I think but if you want to
talk about an original story and again a
story with lots lots of different layers
to it it's a political thriller it's um
in space obviously there's you know
deception and lies and action and
everything as everything in the June
movies spiritualism it goes on and on
and on there's layers upon layers of the
BAM June movie
um
I think it's a bit too conceptual for me
I find it a little boring
it's not the sort of film I would watch
over and over again
um but if you are talking about high
concept sci-fi
you can't really do much better than
June
I would argue
Harris what is your final
throw the bass so so I'm I'm gonna cheat
just a little bit too little uh
honorable mentions in real quick because
uh I I wanted to throw it
no okay no throwing honorable mentions
you're gonna get a chance to do
honorable mentions before we decide what
our top five are just all right number
one is now okay well then I don't have
to give my big old Spiel I Was preparing
all right well let me let me dive into a
quick little story then of course
because you know M cubed where where my
myself my channel yada yada you know it
means movies and then money and then I
love talking about them things but the
last last bit of that is oh good old
Mary Jane and uh of course I moved to
California because I like movies and I
like little Greenery so
one thing that has always stuck to me
was the most I have ever smoked walking
into a movie was like 15 16 years old
walking into Interstellar
and it has stuck with me as just it was
it blew my my mind it blew my socks off
it blew anything it just
pot you know like it was it was amazing
it stays amazing Christopher Nolan is
just
phenomenal at what he does he's he's a
master at the art if if if he's not the
best sci-fi guy ever it's got to be
Kubrick or James Cameron it's one of
those three I mean it has to be right uh
sure we can toss somebody else up there
but Christopher Nolan is just he's a
master at what he does the film itself
is perfect just someone that likes to
act not necessarily wants to act but
likes to act and enjoys the art aspect
of it that type of project to be able to
sink into any of those characters would
be
oh I would be a dream come true it's
just that film is
so weird to to wrap your head around at
times especially in that third act but
to be McConaughey and go through and see
your family kind of age alongside you
but not alongside you it's just it's
been done before but it has never been
done as meticulously and precisely as
well Chris Nolan does so thank you for
that
we talked about practical stuff instead
of CGI over uh earlier and Christopher
Nolan makes sure that practical effects
are
definitely uh prioritized over CGI and
you can just tell the fact that he
we talk about the economics of films
sometimes that man literally bought a
cornfield and paid off the entire movie
by selling the crops of the cornfield
for Interstellar
genius
how they used a real black hole as well
yeah I don't know where he found it but
he managed it
is a fantastic film and that that was
going to be on my list at somewhere
because I couldn't stop thinking about
that film but I've
I've not seen enough time for it to be
like my all-time favorite but I
absolutely love it for everything you've
just said and like it's like the super
realistic like the attention to detail
like the the thing in the end I still
can't wrap my head around it like I
don't understand it but I [__] love
it
like it makes it to a degree but then
you're like how many other degrees do I
need to actually make sense of this is
the thing I didn't I think the thing
that just I I just couldn't get around
my head why the hell was he in the
library
you know that little room and he's
pulling the books out why
everything else I got the whole the
entire dilation thing but the library
bit like what
quantum mechanics that's been what I
thought of interstellar
the what you hate it you hated it
it's boring
the robot was stupid
um Hathaway is lovely though I love Anne
Hathaway she's a very beautiful lady
um I I know everyone said all the
attention to detail thing the whole end
sequence there is no science behind that
whole end sequence where he's behind the
books I know it's technically quantum
mechanics and things but no
um
I just I find it boring
I know I just didn't like it I don't
like Crystal I love the Batman movies
except for the third one I thought the
third one was too potasse
um tenet is is stupid
it's so boring I want to blow my own
brains out rather than watching it
I've got around to watching that one yet
don't bother it's
well you've probably stoned watching yes
stupid it's just it's boring it's badly
acted
it's it's it even though it's incredibly
expensive film to make it comes across
quite cheap
it's badly edited
yeah honestly I hated it I took the kids
I thought you were talking about
Interstellar still here
I'm riding no tenant was quite cheaply
it it's not cheap to make it was very
expensive maybe yeah quite cheap
um I just hate it paid it I've watched
it once I'm never watching it again
I'm sorry
that was going to be my honorable
mentions
because that was teachering on on the
list like should I put it on there
should I not but because I I went down
the nostalgic route it's not anything
that's told you I just I just like the
film it is good it's a personal list
we've created an also his Nostalgia for
me from uh my little bit of greenery so
we might have to put a little Nostalgia
to one side I mean I I would I would
love to have watched that stones that
experience must have been insane me and
two of my really great friends at the
time just walked in and we we probably
we had no business walking in I don't
know how we made a door of seats we were
high school kids just stoned out of our
minds and then just wandering
plop ourselves in the middle of the
movie theater and then just lost it for
three and a half hours just kind of came
back and was like oh
oh the world's still okay thankfully yes
good okay no no dust or anything we're
good Selena you experience time dilation
in real time it felt like it that's for
sure what was the Leonardo DiCaprio film
but they have to go through the
different layers and it's all in dreams
Inception well that was my honorable
mention I watched that stone
um but yeah okay right so we got we've
got our five lists so mine Predator
underscore
um Undiscovered Country RoboCop aliens
and the Matrix we've got June contact
2001 Space Odyssey Moon and aliens from
our stormy Matt Planet the Apes E.T
Matrix Back to the Future Terminator two
or Terminator we're not really bothered
and Harris Fantastic Planet Blade Runner
Matrix again 2001 Space Odyssey and
Interstellar that are our lists we have
to pick our top five of our favorite
Sci-Fi movies of all time which will
become the Sidetrack official until we
change it or do this video again or
actually just change our minds
our official top five but before we do
that we can throw in a couple of
honorable mentions a couple of movies
that maybe aren't really strong Frank
um or aren't pure sci-fi so we didn't
want to put it on the list
I'm just going to throw a ball straight
out there
Ghostbusters
it is a sci-fi movie it is one of the
book but it's primarily a comedy
so I couldn't earn it you know ghosts
but you know it is still sci-fi
it's one of the greatest movies ever
made it's again about perfection it's
just beautifully made
um and the original Ghostbusters
obviously not the one with the ladies
which was still a good film I'm not a
sexist pig they didn't ruin it just
because they've got boobs
or maybe they did a little bit but it's
just a bad film so it's not funny as a
comedy and that's like the straight up
thing at the beginning isn't it just
terrible so but yeah Ghostbusters the
original Ghostbusters Perfection
if I love this I want to throw in as
well but guys
Men in Black
oh you got him again again in terms of
nostalgia for me I watched that
so much
the second one was all right and the
third one
I actually enjoyed the third one
actually the second was okay the the
first one though
Perfection the scene where the ship
crashes down and goes through the globe
and just crashes on the floor oh [__]
love it I would rewind that scene and
just watch it over and over again
because I love it yeah
oh
Big Trouble in Little China is a
brilliant film and they're remaking it
which is a crime but it's not sci-fi
with magic it was magic and wizards and
things like that but um brilliant movie
I can't believe it's ridiculous my
neighbor just turned on their very loud
cars with that noise is
what I'm a tournament
oh I didn't hear it my my speakers
aren't right how about you Harrison what
got any others on your throwing
ignore the noise at the time okay okay
okay uh well inceptions on my honorable
mention but one that I I just love it's
not great but they just announced the
fourth one and I'm so excited for it
pitch black I I love Riddick give me
some Riddick it's cheesy it's it's
Chronicles
I one of my first film memories is uh uh
oh my God what's his name Vin Diesel
there we go I wanted to say Vince Vaughn
for a second I just got the VIN in my
head Vin Diesel killing the guy with a
teacup in in Pitch Black it's so good
it's so bad it's so good I love it I
love it that was in the Chronicles it
wasn't it does it a bam shop wow yeah I
love that
um I tell you what somebody track gate
and myself have
Spaceballs
um again if you're a regular site
tracker you might have heard me ranting
about Spaceballs
well on another life
um I can't remember what we're talking
about but Spaceballs I want them
desperately to remake Spaceballs or do a
reboot of Spaceballs Spaceballs 2 the
search for more money
um with Star Trek a Star Wars sorry so
popular at the moment I mean come on MGM
Amazon just do a parody it's primed it's
like it's like the the sequels gave
everybody the perfect thing to just
paint the picture for Spaceballs too
which is yeah exactly it's just it's
beautiful we need it and again not
really a Sci-Fi but I want to see them
go in La plat one more time
um ridiculous speed I just I just I want
I need to see it it's you know
um I'm a mark I'm half Dark Half Human
I'm My Own best friend this this needs
to be
back in our lives and we need the shorts
one more time so yeah jumper someone's
just mentioned jumper
again it's not really science
my other honorable mention
Ed a good film is you've already
mentioned it is martian the Martian
it's a good film but it's a fantastic
book yeah so if you if if you want to if
you want to experience it in its
entirety either listen to it on Audible
like I did or buy the book it's
fantastic Andy Weir is a fantastic
author and the second project here on
Mary right you like that one a lot too
yeah yeah yeah yeah we spoke about this
before haven't we yeah project Hail Mary
is so much better
and they're making a film out of it yeah
yeah yeah in time we're just going to be
a brilliant film I love that film uh
who's gonna be the guy I think it was
Ryan Gosling Ryan Gosling is going to be
yeah Mary no way okay okay nice so good
so good I'm gonna I'm gonna live re-read
it because it was that good I haven't
read project Hail Mary but I want to I I
really do it's so good
um a Robocop
um returns is apparently still planned
at MGM and Amazon but they've only just
recently got ahead of movies so give it
time but a robot another RoboCop movie
with Peter Weller
sorry Peter Weller or Joel Kinnaman
uh no it'll be a new active chances are
but um this is supposed to be storyline
it will be a direct sequel to the
original there was okay right so there
was a there was a script for a sequel
um that was always supposed to be done
but then RoboCop was so popular they
rushed and they wanted a movie quickly
and the script just wasn't ready so they
rushed robocopter which is still I
actually really enjoyed it still but
they rushed it but there was a storyline
written by the original writers
um for a sequel and that's what they're
basing are supposedly basing the next
sequel on but it'll be very much
stranger things the 80s
um it's supposed to be a direct sequel
so let's see what they do it could be
horrific but it could be really really
good if they get if they get the tone
right
that could be really really good
hopefully it's cool do we know who's uh
the filmmakers behind it it's not got
that far yet they've only Amazon have
got as far as planning and then Paul
verhoven has been in talk sir so the
original
created to come back pretend because if
he doesn't come back Netflix is almost
done with stranger things you just
mentioned Duffer Brothers need something
cool and they like their sci-fi
and they've got that they could get the
tone right I think if they wanted to do
something that was set sort of back then
and do it like like an immediate sequel
something so yeah my most definitely
um for me I wanted to just throw in a
couple of numbers like the day they
stood still as a classic sci-fi movie
black and white not the Keanu Reeves
remake
um
it it's just one of those films it was
it's one of the ultimate B movies and
it's really a film that's starting an
entire genre
um it's it's still a great film now and
again it's 100
should be in anyone's movie never mind
sci-fi education you move the education
why that film got made what it means
what is this and fly to the Navigator
which is another film they're planning
to remake and there is absolutely no
need that film still looks good now the
special effects even though it's 30
years old still look fine they still
look great and they'll just mess it up
but fly to the Navigator again if you've
got kids any kid'll love it it's such a
great movie
there is one sci-fi film we haven't
mentioned and I'm surprised no one's
mentioned it so it deserves to be in the
honorable mentions and it is Stark
this target no one's mentioned it
it's a great film it kick-started one of
the greatest things that we all have
something in common about so
yeah true you know another that we
haven't mentioned yet it's not Stargate
related but it came out I think the year
before or after Jurassic Park that's
just excellent oh God
ever honestly and it's just it's it's so
easy to look over it with all these
different like Concepts and these just
fun like badass sci-fi things that we're
thinking about because there's no aliens
and spaceships it's dinosaurs it's the
other way it's true science just our
science I guess we think of Science
Fiction being futuristic don't we but
actually this case was prehistoric and
but yeah 100 literally
um I've been checking the list of them
going through
um Armageddon great fun movie no I'm not
a classic but a fun movie always worth
watching the thing I would argue maybe
that's a horror movie yeah just a remake
of
um making the body snatches really
um from a concept point of view but
classic movie brilliant special effects
stands up today fantastic film
um ultraviolet was on the list there as
somebody mentioned um Galaxy Quest
great film yeah because it's great but
it is a comedy
um and and yeah and then there's
somebody else mentioned Jupiter ascended
I think they might have been joking
okay
so I'm I am having a look at the list
right uh just see if any stand out to me
this one is stand has stood out
but I wouldn't necessarily consider it
sci-fi
Flubber
oh it's kind of sci-fi is it sci-fi it's
a good film but is it sci-fi well it's
comedy but it's it's it's sci-fi ask no
um the last two I'm just gonna throw out
there just just come up there
Independence Day
great film the original yeah The Fifth
Element
oh you're talking about conceptual
movies as well the fifth element is a
phenomenal movie and it's proper sci-fi
one I didn't cross in there was uh I
wanted to but it might have been a
wrench it just it just doesn't fit
without dive was Wally Wally's just
another great one
if we're gonna do animated Sci-Fi movies
maybe that's another video we'll do
another time but yeah it will definitely
be in there we've got a Fantastic Planet
up in there huh right let's start
throwing through guys we need to start
talking about a few drama
no I tweeted at him yesterday
right I've got to go very shortly so we
need a top five gentlemen so I think the
only thing that I think we're all going
to agree on that deserves to probably be
the top five it's a 2001 A Space Odyssey
do we agree yeah
that in Matrix probably
I was gonna say and maybe the Matrix so
we won't maybe do an order on this
because I think it's too difficult
because there's lots of different
reasons why so we got we got we've got
two we're on a roll back to the future
has to be in there no it doesn't
um yes it does it's it's iconic
yeah
what are all the options again just can
you give us like the list of options
let's go through our lists predator and
predator and predator
Space Balls
um I I mean I'm I'm willing to I have a
discussion about The Fifth Element about
the list that people that you know the
subscribers have thrown in that I think
worth a worth of conversation and the
abyss
and close encounters
um
A Fantastic Planet Blade Runner Matrix
2001 Interstellar it was easier to throw
out names here right guys are we
throwing out the Predator even though I
say it's a perfect movie is it a perfect
sci-fi movie it it feels more action
even Safeway
okay Undiscovered Country I'm more than
one to throw out RoboCop I think we
should definitely have a conversation
about that's yeah aliens
aliens
it's difficult one but we'll leave it in
for now and we'll go aliens over RoboCop
we are a democracy unless I put my foot
down and decide the winner
um so I'm I'm willing to so I'm going to
put a question mark on aliens for a
second
stormy's list June contact 2001 Moon and
aliens
so that's two votes for aliens really
um Matt Planet the Apes I mean I'm not a
fan yeah don't don't put it on the top
five because it's not
um
Back to the Future I'm willing to have a
conversation about and Terminator two
I'm willing to have a conversation about
right Harris Fantastic Planet
mates too conceptual
oh yeah no there's no way it's a great
movie and it's historic it's there's a
historic relevance to it but
it's like it's an education thing it's
not
I think so um
[Music]
you've got 2001 in there
I I'm gonna remove Interstellar
and and I know I am putting my foot down
on this because it's stupid and it's
boring so Blade Runner hang on if this
is democracy I like Interstellar yeah
wait a second
that's my democracy I mean
it's a Jay Tater it's it's my democracy
so Jay Toyota ship yeah Blade Runner
King Jay
I Am Lord Jay
yeah
okay we can have a conversation about
Interstellar but it'll be a short one
so why should I put Interstellar in the
top five
because it's good
not good enough no cost of that already
no five that's the future you have to
replace it then
and Back to the Future still in the
conversation
Jesus Christ people guys get to the
comments you know you're allowed to
you're allowed to weigh in on this um if
I get 10 people next five minutes going
come on Interstellar
I'll throw it in all right come on come
on come on yo
I'm trying to encourage
or just saying no
um right so we've got back to the future
I've got five spaces here guys so we've
got we've got to be harsh we've got
three spaces left so we have options at
the moment of I think
um The Fifth Element Jurassic Park the
thing Independence Day Close Encounters
um and on our lists we've got still
having a chat about Back to the Future
Terminator 2 and Blade Runner
now I think all of those have
a good argument to get on this list
back to the future if we're talking
about popular
you can't get much more can you
everyone yeah even people who don't like
sci-fi like Back to the Future
all right so I mean I wouldn't even say
that we're popular it's even if you
forget it's it's actually sci-fi
yeah well someone in the comments
mentioned said it's uh comedy not a
Sci-Fi it is a Sci-Fi it has comedic
elements but so do most great sci-fi's
so
yeah I think it's it's not an out and
out comedy
yeah there aren't many jokes in it
it's not like
um Space Balls which isn't out and out
comedy or even Ghostbusters which is I
think primarily a comedy is written by a
comedian
um it's it's got a few jokes in it so I
know I think it's it's primarily a
Sci-Fi you can argue it's a Sci-Fi
Action comedy maybe but it's sci-fi I'll
I'll give you that
um
so The Matrix it appeared on almost all
of our lists
oh yeah yeah yeah
um but that should be in there
100 maybe been let down by
sequels a little bit but yeah the
original just I've already written it
down I think the original's so strong it
doesn't matter what the sequels yeah I
think about the the sequels 100
you know what guys I'm thinking we we
really are are we going to go Terminator
or aliens
oh can we just say James Cameron
well they both deserve to be on the list
because T2
I I I I I struggle to decide between
Terminator and TT
or aliens and Terminator too no I mean
actually literally between the original
Terminator movie in Terminator two I've
struggled to pick one for different
reasons I love them both
aliens I think is more a horror movie
than it isn't it a Sci-Fi
um
I think terminated I've got aliens
there's a sci-fi movie it's an action
sci-fi but it's a sci-fi movie
I think aliens has got to be on the list
because I mean
how would you feel about a list that was
2001 Space Odyssey The Matrix Back to
the Future aliens and Terminator 2.
as our top five
that's yeah that works for me
I'm not opposed by any means there's
just so many other like you just just
the honorable mention of Jurassic Park
and things like that just make you want
to talk to me like that in there but
alien how can you complain about an
impossible list to make isn't it ever
made the list and have it be
oh we've just wasted it down off if we
can sit here away every single film
that's been on that list we'd be here
for another hour so a couple days maybe
any films on here though that you
there's a few films I could swap out
here June there you could argue that all
day oh yeah you've been argue like you
said you're asking classic Park all day
there aren't that's a that's five films
that okay we'll put it this way five
films that have influenced sci-fi
an influenced Cinema
and we've got
2001 A Space Odyssey The Matrix
Terminator 2 Back to the Future in
Aliens
well if we're gonna say specify that I'm
gonna toss Fantastic Planet back in the
ring but that just complicates things on
because if we're influence alone you
said Captain Planet Captain Planet he's
a hero he's gonna take pollution down to
zero if Don cheadle's Captain Planet
then yes
bunk bunks back
hello
John Carter that's uh oh I I love John
Carter that never gets a good rap that
was let down by the casting well I
honestly I don't mind the cast
equilibrium was just wouldn't I just
copy The Matrix
yeah good film yeah I liked it but it
felt like it was copy of the Matrix to
me 13th floor great film dark city great
film Demolition Man
demolition manage may be a bit too
it's more of an action movie and more of
a thing but but yeah no it's it's a
classic movie absolutely fantastic
really really good list there
and best name of anybody in here tonight
did y'all see that interaction in the in
the chat right above and below that real
quick Bob said where's where's this
what's this June movie and someone said
um
it just cracked me up
um um
yeah I don't say my D's on my T's very
well either so what you think what you
think guys what to think what
do you think
um I'm sorry do you know I think he
means tuna it's
so good film thank you epics thank you
um not a Sci-Fi but yeah but but no okay
so we have got a list there that I would
say that maybe they're not
I think if you're going to influence if
you're talking from the info it's an
entertainment point of view you would
watch any of these films a million times
yes and you'll never get bored of it
yeah
influence entertainment perfect but
there are so many movies on here that
have got like Close Encounters
that you really struggle to to argue War
of the Worlds even
um perhaps in
yeah well Paul Malone's just put the fly
yeah so
I think I was having like our top five
our official top five is difficult but
because like I say undiscovered country
for me
it's it's such an important movie to me
and like Matt's entire list
it's it's films as important to him you
know it's like um
you can't take away from that so what I
might do
I will say that's our official top five
of most influential Sci-Fi movies and I
think that's fair is that sound fair
yeah whatever but our top five is our
own lists
because that it's so important to us and
and it's really difficult to say any
more than that because they're just it's
just
like I said predator for me is just it's
perfect how do you not have that on the
top five it's perfect it's Perfection
but
who's playing music
does that mean
I think it's not for you
we're live and someone's phoning is
ridiculous right I put my phone on on
the play button
how unprofessional guys thank you so
much for again an entertaining video
um I don't think we've achieved anything
and I don't think we've decided anything
no we're gonna giggle but we talked
about some great films
and we had shits and giggles and guys
everyone in the comments again thank you
so so much you've been absolutely
legendary as you always always are and
just a few more comments come in
um it's your list the way it should be
generalization thank you so so much one
good comment earlier was uh from R I
think they said we should do a top five
b list Sci-Fi movies at one at some
point that's our next that we will do
that in a couple of weeks I think it's a
very very good idea because
um
yeah I mean the b-list movie you can see
we're going to end up arguing over that
again though oh yeah it's gonna be fun
for the list what's a beam I think it's
got to be a bit cheesy somebody
mentioned uh oh the film with the with
the wrestler no I don't matter I'll talk
about next week but yeah in a couple of
weeks we will do that I I love these top
fives I think it's I think
I just love the um
the thing the Crossovers you know like
things like everyone's always I've said
the Matrix and why but I love it when
somebody just throws out something
completely [__] random as well it's
just um that's great
um
huh yeah what what Futurama what if the
best movie ever
the best sci-fi series ever you idiot
amazing fun game all good fun all good
fun but guys thank you so so much
say bye everybody
see you guys see you next week have a
good
[Music]